i want to talk about two things we've
talked about many times before but not
together
and those two topics are on the one hand
anti and pseudo-intellectualism and on
the other hand the covid19 pandemic now
covet of course we've talked about
for a year and a half every week and
sometimes even more often we've tracked
cases we've tracked deaths
variants masks vaccines and everything
in between
we've also talked about
anti-intellectual and
pseudo-intellectual movements and that's
a really big topic and this goes back to
the genesis of
american intellectualism in the 1800s or
even arguably earlier than that but it
also includes simply an analysis
of people who read books by by authors
like tucker carlson and bill o'reilly
and they start to think that they're
educated and they have a well-rounded
and
nuanced and detailed view of how the
world works and
the belief that one is much more
informed than they actually are but
these two issues
anti-intellectualism and covid are very
much linked
there's a really good study in nature
that was published a few months ago
called anti-intellectualism and the mass
public's response
to the covet 19 pandemic and when i was
looking through this recently i realized
that many of our previous discussions
about anti-intellectualism
apply perfectly to what's been going on
with this pandemic in the united states
it applies to mask wearing
it applies to anti-vaccine sentiment and
to so much more
and the article does a number of
different things to assess how people
came to believe incorrect things
about the pandemic be it about the virus
itself or about public health measures
or vaccines or whatever else
and the conclusion is not going to be a
surprise the article finds quote
we provide evidence of a consistent
connection
between anti-intellectualism and covid19
risk perceptions
social distancing mask usage
misperceptions
and information acquisition very very
much uh
not unsurprising finding so there are
actually two
sides to the people that still won't get
max
vaccinated that still think masks don't
do anything
who think the virus is fake or whatever
part of it
is that they are part of a political
movement whose leaders spent
basically all of 2020 telling them this
isn't very serious
we don't need to do anything open
everything the economy is what matters
most
that's part of it which is politics
plain and simple
but the side we haven't talked about as
much as the anti-intellectualism a
distrust of scientists and doctors
a distrust of authority feeling that
they know more
uh much like trump always felt that he
knew more than his generals or doctors
or whoever
because they read whatever it was on
facebook or because their uncle told
them whatever it was
now you might say well that
anti-intellectual view
is based on their politics so it really
is still politics and i would agree with
you
but these are still two distinct but
related
phenomena and then the last piece of
this that i want to discuss
is that the anti-intellectualism and the
rejection of science
is very post-modern which these
right-wingers claim to be against
now of course most of the right-wingers
who talk about post-modernism
don't have an iota of a clue not even a
scintilla of an idea
of what post-modernism is but to the
extent that they
sort of understand it right-wingers
claim to hate
the postmodern idea that they say exists
on the left
that every narrative is equally valid
every opinion must be given the same
consideration as every other
and i'll tell you what i'm also against
that i've talked about
my opposition to that idea that every
narrative every idea must be given equal
consideration
but those very same people are
furious that their anti-vaccine
misperceptions
that their covet conspiracy delusions
aren't being given the same weight the
same consideration
the same seat at the table as what
medical doctors
and public health officials and science
says
it's truly the height of hypocrisy so we
have
yes we have a political movement that
spent all of last year saying you don't
really need to worry about this and
that's a big factor
and then yes we also have this
anti-intellectual pseudo-intellectual
component of people who
because they looked at facebook think
that they know as much as
or more than the public health officials
but then the third layer on top of it
is the incredible hypocrisy of being
against
the culture they believe exists on the
left and it exists in some enclaves of
the left although i don't think it's
predominant
that every idea must be given an equal
seat at the table but that's exactly
what they want and what they expect
with their ideas about vaccines and
masks and whatever else and they become
furious
when uh social media platforms or
elected officials or whoever
say hey you know what what you're saying
just isn't based in science so we don't
need to give it equal consideration it's
hypocrisy
anti and pseudo-intellectualism plus the
politics of the republican party around
the virus in 2020.
let me know what you think and is there
something missing from that
three-layered analysis i would love to
hear from you and
uh add to it in a future segment we are
getting very close my friends to the
16th anniversary of the david pakman
show august 16th
is that day the 16th anniversary of the
david pakman show to celebrate
we will be doing a one-day membership
special if you've been listening for one
two three four five six sixteen years
and you've occasionally thought i kind
of like this maybe i'll support it
in some way the perfect day to do it
is august 16th if you want to get an
email
telling you how to take advantage of our
16th anniversary discount
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com